today on our show News News News News
nonsan newsman news involving the poor
kids got fired from Star Wars news about
poor kid got fired from Deadpool - all
news about people got fired and how
everything worked out better for them in
the end today it's not Batman
[Applause]
to that men on Batman welcome the Batman
Batman I'm Kevin mark barnard okay so we
do have a collection news stories here
we do indeed where two of them involve
people that were shit-canned from other
jobs landing on their feet mark seeing
Hollywood people land on their feet
they do and bliss you're Mel Gibson and
even it worked out for him he's got an
Oscar nomination there you go so let's
start with Miller and Lord yes those
guys who got fired from another Star
Wars movie Phil Lord and Chris Miller
indeed I would have bet my life on Chris
Miller and Phil Lord that's what you
said or the other way I would have said
Chris Lord and Phil Miller oh yeah all
right with a gun in my head I would have
been like oh my god I got this one it's
film it and then like you but these two
cats were unceremoniously dumped from
the young Han Solo movie yes and are
responsible for the genius that is the
lego movie and the very funny 21 Jump
Street movie is 22 Jump Street yeah so
you know when they got booted everyone
was like come on any and these two guys
were like where they gonna want us mmm
and like the flash maybe they were
supposed to do the flash they left for
young Han Solo I said that they would
probably scoot ass back to Warner
Brothers where their beloved and you
know [ __ ] make some kind of rich deal
and make a movie and be like to Star
Wars but they didn't do that no they
didn't they instead went to Fox weird to
do a giant science fiction movie what is
that giant science fiction movie mark
it's called Artemis based on a novel
written by Andy weir the same dude who
wrote the Martian I thought uh who wrote
the screenplay for the Martian Drew
Goddard so he didn't uh yeah so what's
this book about mark uh I think it's
about a heist on the moon moon heist
enticed one of those movies yes it's a
lunar story sort of rock you're gonna
have one of the Moon heist movies man
they're doing like three a month now if
you throw a moon rock
and it might miss and then [ __ ] head
toward Earth and after a month speed
into the atmosphere like a giant [ __ ]
comment and burn up to a pebble in the
land until a bunch of dinosaurs like
your version different they're making a
new movie good for them I knew it was
only a matter of time talent outs these
guys got talent [ __ ] yeah they are hotly
in demand all around Hollywood it's
saying wait till they start giving
interviews though those dudes are funny
if it work represents them at all yeah
so I know they'll be able to very
humorously handle this hole yes young
Han Solo there will be lots of funny
under the shade I'd better be writing
some jokes right now we got jokes for
the press junket for Artemis indeed it
follows directionless twenty-something
jazz chafing at the constraints of her
small town a female lead mark Artemis
that's the town which so happens to be
the first and only city on the moon on
the moon of the moon simon kingberg
involved in this as well
yep because they did the Martian also
there in the MV where business oh really
yeah which is a good business mean the
Martian made like six hundred million
dollars I did thinking I thought you
were doing the Chu you were like I got a
rhotic to rock every mouth and I gotta
just quit if you blow an ant off a table
this high and it lands on that floor
will the ant survive yes it'll survive
it won't be a happy ant do you think
it'll just be like my legs there are six
of them are broked no really I mean
that's a pretty steep fall dude yeah but
those cats like they don't like they got
exoskeletons as I previously mentioned
they told me that in 6-8 science you
mean to tell me if I throw an ants off a
table and it hits the floor you might
actually be impacted the way I'd be
impact if I fell off a mountain I mean I
feel as if like the distance between the
dust of the floor would be like throwing
iron man off
Empire State Building without thrusters
I don't want you on this table oh my god
I feel like [ __ ] I'm sorry
welcome to humanity
speaking of horrible truths indeed Jim
Cameron is making a new Terminator movie
yes and a bunch of Avatar movies and a
bunch avatar in selection for avatar two
and three started like Monday and that
is the opposite of a bad thing
see ya been there will like Jim Cameron
stuff he's making this new Terminator
movie with this genius kid named Tim
Miller mm-hm made Deadpool one of those
movies out last year one of the best
movies in the last ten years when the
greatest comic book movies ever made
clearly that movie has a style a voice
and and and a look and Tim Miller was
all of that so now and isn't him not on
Deadpool 2 for whatever reason right
creative differences so he wound up over
and Terminator land gonna make a
Terminator movie with Jim Cameron
himself and that hasn't happened for a
couple pictures indeed Jim Cameron
hasn't been actively involved in
Terminator since Terminator 2 Judgment
Day so this is all cool and exciting all
cool except that's happening but it
means that Jim's out there in the world
talking again he's Otherworld impressed
now he recently what a couple weeks back
[ __ ] about Wonder Woman work he did he
was overseas doing interviews for
Terminator 2 in 3d and said something
about how whatever I don't think it's
good fine but it's no Terminator 2 like
Sarah Connor was actually the trans
aggressive groundbreaking female
character of our time not Wonder Woman
whatever and when he did the internet
went shot the [ __ ] you like everyone got
mad and [ __ ] on some people didn't know
sure but a lot of people got mad a lot
of pieces written about Jim's Cam James
Cameron talking [ __ ] about one come on
what we needed was James Cameron to
mansplain feminism to the world
well-spoken and so patty Jenkins even
commented yeah believe we talked about
it here on this we did and I believe you
read her comments or in your voice but
it was her word yes where she basically
said there's buck off Jim
there's many different ways to be a
strong female character you had your way
and that's great we had our way and
there's you can't tell us how to be
strong and be a woman and there's no
saying that you can't be attractive and
also be strong and she wasn't going like
you're wrong she was just okay there are
many truths yes and when a woman was
never in any way played for sexual sort
of lasciviousness the movie was not from
the male gaze did not objectify her in
the way that most female characters and
movies are no James Cameron was like no
hold my beer I got this so James Cameron
like he could have walked away from all
that I didn't like you know what any
worth the effort but there's a new
Hollywood Reporter article a cover story
on the Jim Cameron and so he sits down
and it's like I'll stand by what I said
no yeah I mean gal gadot was Miss Israel
and she was wearing a kind of bustier
costume that was very form-fitting she's
absolutely drop-dead gorgeous to me
that's not breaking ground Raquel Welch
did the same stuff like that in the 60s
he says to THR why is he tossing shade
at this movie I don't
what is it possibly gain him what does
it possibly lose him
you know bunch of people being like hey
man you know a new cycle that you didn't
need to have is this a reaction because
everyone always goes hey man avatars
just [ __ ] ferngully that may be him
gone like well Wonder Woman's just we
[ __ ] do defers Raquel Welch I don't
know it's a shame man like look I was an
[ __ ] at one point in my career where
I tell everyone what I thought about
people [ __ ] and now if you notice I
generally talk about things I like and I
made quibble with little things you know
I wrote about this at [ __ ] Klingons
like about Star Trek
but generally I only really engage with
things that I I like if you never see me
talking about things chances are I've
not seen them or I've seen them and I
don't like them and there's no point
having the discussion mark likes to [ __ ]
on everything I'm on the other hand
creative [ __ ] very creatively
constructive laid out like you know when
they make pancakes put a face on it oh
he uses his [ __ ] Tom Carvel the dot
eyes make a nose and a big smile doing
good pancakes serves you
tells you it's for creative purpose it's
educational like thanks it's gonna make
it no less tasty yes learn something
from this [ __ ]
regardless point being I I generally
tend to you know [ __ ] say I try stay
positive
yeah this point in my career where I
would say [ __ ] [ __ ] left and right I
said one of the things I regret to this
day is attacking Magnolia because people
were saying way nice things that way
nicer things about it than they were
saying about Dogma in 1999 and Oscar
talking [ __ ] like that and so I got the
screener I hate I hate this but I gotta
tell this story to remind myself what an
[ __ ] I can be I
there was no twitting tweeting then
Martin so I was on my website on the
view skew comm message board and I said
I just received my Oscar screener DVD of
Magnolia and I will be keeping it on my
desk unopened as a constant reminder of
what bloated Self Indulgence looks like
Wow
the guy who made tusks [ __ ] said that
to Paul Thomas Anderson not even to Paul
Thomas Anderson to his family what and
what did that do nothing made me look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] at the end of the
day years later do I like I appreciate
Magnolia more than I did then still not
my [ __ ] big Jam or whatever but
nobody needs to [ __ ] know that nobody
needs to hear me [ __ ] in the mouth
of something that other people [ __ ]
adore other people like it great if it's
a mystery to me now I'm a grown up man
I'm a [ __ ] grown-ass man of 47 so if
there are things where I'm like this
baffles me why anyone would like this
I'm never gonna [ __ ] tell you you
don't need to know you don't need to
know you know what I want to tell you
[ __ ] that I like I'm gonna turn you on
the [ __ ] that I dig I'm not going to
tell you about [ __ ] that I'm like it
didn't do it for me [ __ ] me [ __ ] me in
the mouth James Cameron does not agree
with it may not see things quite the
same way he likes to talk you know I
like to talk to but you don't mind
saying like nah that's crap and this is
good and that is that and this is that
you know why he made movies that have
made billions of dollars and so he
tagged up on it after that by saying as
much as I applaud Pattie directing a
film in Hollywood quote-unquote letting
a woman direct a major action franchise
I don't think there was anything
groundbreaking in wonder what I thought
it was a good film
period I mean
no I guess you know III guess I've
commented on things where I'm like you
know it but just don't know that I would
ever do that but it's it's okay you say
one dumb thing in the press you know
what James Cameron if you ever saw this
would be like well guess what I wouldn't
do make and that's which one of us is
smart fat Kip Smith that's what he'd say
that's what he said but it's also said
that he'd be like fat keV James and I'd
be like Kevin Smith sir huge fan so
sorry yeah I don't know if I mean I I
like that dudes work but everything I
read about him the press seems kind of
prickly yeah and it's like you say
one-time thing and the world tells you
to dumb thing like no taint no here's my
truth DoubleDown super dumb it's so done
at the same time look is entitled to his
opinion he didn't think it was all that
special but that being said it's like
why share that like honestly what does
it gain him like maybe the respect of
some people like I hated it too but the
dudes you couldn't get into those Alamo
Drafthouse screenings like you're right
Jim but it's not like you know people
like hey man everyone should be allowed
to say what they want speak their truths
and stuff yeah sure but like if your
truth is always to be like I wasn't
impressed
you know it's maybe maybe turn that
frown upside down yeah take it a world
or just yeah why not be that guy why not
be he was the king of the world he told
us that when he won an Oscar yeah be the
gracious king of the world we're like
even if you're like like I thought
[ __ ] Wonder Woman was like tepid or
whatever just go like hey good for them
yeah nice job hey priming the pump for
Linda Hamilton to come back for
Terminator 3 yeah like the more the
merrier
yes all we great look how simple that
was come on in for the ladies is that
all can we move on that is all we have
to say much Jim Cameron really it's like
giving a chance to be like remember you
said that [ __ ] about Wonder Woman
probably didn't mean that right he's
like no I did I backed here's some more
on my soul I believe this was true oh
yes
the last we were all young once problem
is Jim is like way over 62 years old
this is like you know [ __ ]
old men know exactly how the world
should be let me tell you what I knew
back in 1972 I couldn't tell my
grandfather nothing well well it's
working today look at the Roger chrome
and creature factory we've all
consciously shared by the ladies the
amazing of James Cameron like rode in to
be like I don't appreciate your racist
turns a [ __ ] on us suddenly people
like yeah why'd you text him Cameron a
Wonder Woman basically I've decided that
Jim Cameron talks like Scatman Crothers
you gotta show me you want to be regular
do you like ice cream doc kick the cave
ah another game of kick and his deliver
is [ __ ] phenomenal
alright man let's move on to some other
some story where people aren't like
[ __ ] Chow and [ __ ] no they're just
spending a [ __ ] ton of money yeah let's
talk about this
so variety I had a report I think this
this week never worked before how
reporter we did however you edited our
reporter right I was I was a senior
editor you would have been the guy who's
like somebody Angeles Jim Cameron story
like [ __ ] Jay here we go you here's the
Polk quote
damn straight I said it and I'll say it
again let's not deserve to Don hold the
burn in hell so wait you did that one
you did ii w w playboy la da la x okay
so you haven't worked for Brian have not
seen Scott I'm not too late I do about
the cycle
I know Maureen Ryan is their TV critic
over there who was super smart and she
was actually important the reporters on
the story which was talking about how
much TV budgets have gone up yeah
and that game of thrones specifically in
the last season they're gonna be six
episodes each episode will be six
episodes left to Game of Thrones pretty
much full of spin-offs begin before
there's been us begin each episode of
those six will cost fifteen million
dollars each so six times 15 is 90 yep
so you're getting six hours of Game of
Thrones for 90 million dollars
yes show me we live we're here and tell
them we're here in Hollywood Hills okay
right you can't see offset but over
there Hollywood over there the hills and
Burbank so studios their Studios there
you show me one [ __ ] studio can make
a six hour movie with dragons in it then
you give a [ __ ] about with a great story
for ninety million dollars that's
amazing to me
I mean thanks [ __ ] that's insane
that's what a great price and now in a
world where it's like you don't got to
make grants and [ __ ] like that in movie
biz like yeah you still got marketing
[ __ ] but that's that's that figure
doesn't even include marketing it's not
even I'll go on like and then you know
this is what we spend on [ __ ] ad buys
for anything that's just literally
making the production yep six hours of
television yeah some of which will have
dragons in it a lot of which has special
effects yes an army of [ __ ] dead
people I think that's a steal maybe I'm
crazy call me [ __ ] crazy but that's
that seems cheap to me it uh when you
look at it that way you're absolutely
right yes you look at a different prison
when you look at it in comparison to
every other TV show on the planet that
is more money that's ever been spent on
a television show my hand is raised yes
sir you can't compare this to every
other show on the planet this may be the
greatest television experience of our
lifetime and I'm not saying it won't get
better down the run down the line but
right now what's better than this so
[ __ ] the standard of everything else or
what other [ __ ] costs this is a
phenomena unlike anything else
absolutely the thing of it is though if
this was a 90 million dollar movie they
went six hours you broke it into three
two our movies yes you could make 200
million dollar you could make a billion
dollars off of those movies yes it is
unclear what the revenue stream for HBO
Game of Thrones is they need more
subscribers like that's what it is they
are being pirated at an ungodly rate
right DVD sales are have always been for
the last ten years trickling to a bare
minimum almost not exist almost they
sell strong on iTunes when they put
their series up right for the season but
it's it's one of those like yes it's
absolutely like how are they gonna make
the money back how did they make the
money back how does anybody make the
money back
as Netflix make their money back is it
subscribers entirely Netflix is spending
they spent six million dollars an
episode on stranger things the first
season there's 8 million in episode for
the season 2 they spent 10 million in
episode on the crown the 2 million
between stranger think season Gabi
raises probably raises problem it
affects work like it's gonna be a bigger
show I think this year than it was last
year but all of these companies are
spending all of this money on all of
this content which looks great but none
of it looks bad but it becomes so much
Westworld cost anybody know um West
world I think was between eight and ten
million dollars that looked expensive
looked expensive you know and they and
[ __ ] shooting it up in Santa Clarita
in the heat where it's like ton of it is
exteriors and not even counting the we
got a build a [ __ ] futuristic bunker
yeah like that's yeah that's money
that's money it's all money and the
thing of it is is if every one of these
streaming platforms is spending this
much money on stuff if Hulu was spending
you know eight million dollars in
episode on whatever stars is spending
eight million on American Gods even if I
can TNT's will that period drama
starring young Will Shakespeare five
million six million dollars in episode
on TNT for sure they got cancelled after
first season I think the CW shows up
three and four pop - I mean that's kind
of about what network is Network is
about you know between two and four
million no scandal costs anybody know I
don't know something a cheap show rise
just people talking yeah kind of like
it's not a lot of work crashing planes
but one of those a talent overall five
years well it created the show must get
yeah Shonda gets her piece I'm sure that
Olivia Pope is not begging for money but
when how long can this sustain how long
can television be produced at this cost
let me ask you something you talk about
TV bubble here give a single this is
important it's if go go go tell him tell
him about the bubble mark warned them
jor-el there are something like 400
scripted shows on TV now more than
they've ever been in the history of
television
each episode of these shows are costing
more and more and more on platforms that
are not driven by advertising they're
driven by subscribers that driven by
traffic but they're not driven by
Procter & Gamble's buying half an hour
of the show to sell
soap that's what TV is at its core it's
the space between commercials yes the
broadcast TV cable TV a little bit
different pay cable absolutely different
streaming different even still so for
how much longer can these this much
money be spent on content before
everybody realizes oh [ __ ] my CBS all
access to app is not bringing in the
traffic we wanted it to we can monetize
this much traffic to pay for the content
we're putting on and nobody knows how
long it'll last nobody knows how much
longer we'll be living in this rarefied
air of everybody gets a show and every
show cost the hunting knowledge to make
mmm sub comic book men which returns
October 22nd doesn't cost that much to
make seven years running yeah TV man is
a baffling business you're right when
you put it through that prism how are
they gonna make that money back they
just they have to get new subscribers
yeah and like how many people and you're
right they're hemorrhaging subscribers
because people are like I'm gonna watch
this [ __ ] on for free yes oh may they
show you stats all the time like
millions of people watching this [ __ ]
for free yeah like the most pirated show
in history is Game of Thrones not even
counting the people like can I use your
HBO now login and yeah they're not
paying for it either so it's it's I mean
it's a glorious time to be making
television this is all your fault you
[ __ ] people that refused to pay for a
show as good as Game of Thrones man
you're the are they the problem no I
don't think so you know the problem well
you're not helping I think it's it's a
bit of a gold rush I mean we saw it with
the the OTT networks remember when
everybody was like we going on like
YouTube red and we're doing stuff in
each pay to download never they were
dancing and ultimately nobody kind of
wanted to pay for that look I I luckily
enough I got a job where I can write off
the cost of all these app channels
because it's like hey man I'm in the
entertainment business I got to do
research got to be familiar with what's
out there
so but that being said I got a lot of
app channels got myself a Netflix
cutting some Hulu and got myself a CBS
access now got myself Amazon got myself
well that's wind-up screen junkies that
counts but I count it sure you're paying
for it bable vision com
yes I signed up for my own [ __ ]
service so I could watch my
show on my phone but that's a lot a nine
bucks ten bucks a pop like right there
that's fifty sixty bones yeah Disney's
about to start up there so yeah and I
want that you want I want the CW or
Warner Brothers or the DC app shell
whatever they're talking about we're
gonna put all the CW shows and all the
cartoons and [ __ ] like this just makes
sense and I want it I want it all but
you're right there's gonna come a point
where look I can afford I've worked my
ass off and I but you know I work Mazza
but I'm out working a lot sure and and
making that money so I can buy many app
channels what happens is the person
that's just like I got one job I got no
job I can't afford no app Channel yeah
it's like cable was too expensive I had
[ __ ] that I didn't watch so I got rid of
cable but now I got to do all of this
other [ __ ] I'm still spending 150 bucks
a month to get what I used to get and
one check now I'm sending out eight
checks what if it was cheaper what if
instead of $9.99 it was like $4.99 five
bucks
I mean people why won't they let us live
in a $5 world because I got ten million
dollar in episode budgets for these
things is the problem right that's the
problem I was just praising fifteen
million bucks I'm like hey how come the
same cheaper like because you just this
is it could be an issue it could be an
issue so that initial yang in our
continuing expose of the TV bubble that
we'll be looking at like for right now
everybody seems happy to spend this
money it's a gold rush for content and
eyeballs but [ __ ] Krypton before the
explosion is what he's saying yes it is
that's right yes have a good time like
we don't need to have sex any more or
less birth the baby's and chambers and
[ __ ] it's fine there's only a little bit
of crime and witness endlessly so
Phantom Zone it's a chance let us all
sorry
doctors and people that what is that
rumbling all right man so we'll keep an
eye on us that's all the news well we
got a live show coming out [ __ ] yeah we
got a live show man what are you doing
go buy tickets right now go to see smoke
on a c-spot I came to say my own address
safe for me see smog calm there I said
it and buy tickets for a fat man I'm
Batman lie lie October 10th and October
17th and the 17th square scum and
villainy you watched the long episode of
him and that long-ass episode we did to
another hours that we recorders scum and
villainy
that's a game changer for us we threw it
up on that channel you know it's one
thing you do 10 minute 20 minute shows
you get 50,000 views 50,000 people sat
through two and a half hours of us
standing me on a [ __ ] bar I felt like
we were in cheers big audience and we
were at a bar and he had perfect [ __ ]
hair just like so yes go to see smart
calm get tickets man join us at scum and
villainy Cantina right there on
Hollywood Boulevard nice spot but you
gotta act fast cuz it's not a lot of
seats in that house and they sold out
quick last time it's just a very quick
last time if you watch that show you see
it's a good [ __ ] time and we talk and
then you guys talking yeah we all sit
around get drunk and well you guys get
drunk I'm blazed and and talk about [ __ ]
that we love an environment it's crazy
you sit around a bar and talk about geek
[ __ ] like unheard who knew who knew this
was a job you could have yes so go buy
them tickets man yeah that's all the
news we got for you for now first taste
was free next taste is you gotta buy
them tickets then you know if you can't
get out here you'll be able to see the
show see right here taken carry him yeah
man
got you all ends and you know we're
gonna do quiz yes
quiz with prizes I get a lot of [ __ ]
like people give me [ __ ] all the time so
it's like I could give away prizes not
like keV this is some meaningful to me
you know people give you free [ __ ] like
here's a Batman something so you know we
could bring it in and [ __ ] have the
quiz whoever wins BAM prize you get an
ad at from Star Wars chili mmm-hmm
so go buy tickets gonna be a good time
in that's it that's all the news we got
for you [ __ ] off for fat man about me
I've been given mark barnard come back
next time same bat-time same bat-channel
Spock ask how more youtube.com slash
Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
you